if you're looking for tips and tricks on
publishing with pubsub then you're in
the right place number one batch
messages by batching messages you can
increase throughput but larger batches
also mean increased latency number two
be mindful when using ordering Keys
publishing messages with an ordering key
might slightly increase end-to-end
message delivery latency since Cloud Pub
sub takes steps to coordinate the
storage and delivery of messages across
different servers when using ordered
delivery number three use a regional end
point since ordered delivery is only
guaranteed within a region using a
regional endpoint instead of a global
endpoint to publish messages to the same
region can be especially useful